we found this statement on the seed and
spark website if you add up the cable
bills the video streaming subscriptions
and all of the movie tickets sold
americans spend 120 billion which
calculates to 396 dollars each on video
entertainment in 2012 and somewhere
between eighty to ninety four percent of
that money went to the companies that
deliver the content not to the actual
artist that created those films correct
where do you see the future of
filmmaking and distribution in the next
five to ten years that being said so
we're already seeing it be massively
disintermediated right which means you
don't need three or four gatekeepers in
between you and your audience anymore
thanks to this thing right you can reach
your audience directly it has never been
true before that the tools that Beyonce
and the President of the United States
used to reach their audience you also
have in your pocket like I don't think
people still have fully comprehended the
power in that alone but the authoring
tools that are available to the most
famous most prestigious and wealthiest
are also available to you and me right
which is not to say you are not yourself
extraordinarily prestigious I think the
the distant remediation is tremendous I
also think it will become way more
decentralized so because these tools are
available look I just spent 35 days i
went to 26 cities and i met people in
Memphis and Houston and South Jordan
Utah and Bellingham Washington and there
are filmmakers in all of these places
who don't want to move have no interest
of paying the rents that we pay in Los
Angeles or that we pay in New York or
even honestly that you pay in Austin
Texas and they want to make films and
they could make a really good living for
themselves at sixty thousand dollars a
year right so if your ambition is not to
become rich and famous with filmmaking
but to make the work that's really
meaningful to you and get it to an
audience to
whom it is also really meaningful I
believe that pretty soon we will see
people we will actually see the rise of
a creative middle class in the film
industry that is not in New York in LA
because it's too flippin expensive to
live there but actually you know if you
could make five films a year one of
which is yours for which are ones that
you're working on your friends and
they're 100 120 thousand dollar budgets
some are bigger some are smaller you
know you keep yourselves sort of
furiously dedicated to making the most
excellent versions of the things you
rely on your peers to make you better
you use every technology available to
you to make it inexpensively and to
connect directly with the audiences to
whom it matters along the way I think we
will see filmmakers making a sustainable
living and again I don't mean getting
rich and famous I do mean maybe making
enough money to feed their families and
hopefully make little artist babies and
make you know more empathic people in
the world yeah so I think it's it's the
way that everything is going right much
more decentralized much more
disintermediated I think there's some
big big question marks out there that
are a little scary right so you know we
have this question out there about net
neutrality and of course net neutrality
would be very bad for a company like
seeds and the lack of net neutrality
seed and spark but you know Google is
out there laying fiber all over the
world and they might effectively create
a two-tier internet if their fiber is
way faster than the stuff that's
currently available to us through our
crappy cable companies right and if they
effectively create a 22 your internet
just out of like convenience that's a we
have to hope that they really meant it
when they said don't be evil right
that's one piece of it and I think there
are some corporations out there that are
creating conglomerates that are putting
a lot of pressure on
the way that the distribution business
can build and grow think lack of data is
very damaging to us right now if i could
leave behind a legacy that i would be
most proud of it would be in sort of
spearheading or joining or or
encouraging the effort to get companies
like Netflix to release the viewership
data to the filmmakers so the filmmakers
had any hope of building better business
models based on the data that Netflix is
collecting I think it's at this point if
your user data is your only competitive
advantage you better think about what
you're offering to people so I think
it's really really essential for us to
as filmmakers an artist demand that we
get the most data we can get so we can
learn about the audience's how they view
what they view what it means to them
where they're viewing things to whatever
extent we can so that we can build
smarter business models I think if we
continue to sort of beat our head
against the wall of like I'm going to
make a movie 43 million with stars in it
and I'm going to take it to a big
festival and whatever we'll have a lot
of really disappointed disenfranchised
artists because a few people will get to
do that and you know the rest of the
folks who are trying to do that will
sort of fall by the wayside I think you
have to we have to be highly educated in
the tools that are available up to us to
dominate our independent careers they
are available those tools are available
we now have to demand the data I think
that you know is it as an essential
component of it and provided we don't
have sort of a tyrant to to your
internet or we don't lose net neutrality
altogether I think we can rely on the
distribution getting you know faster
cheaper better all the time because
that's what the audience demands
ultimately you know so this middle class
artists how do you envision them being
paid
need from if they're going to wreck to
the consumer in this theoretical five to
10-year landscape how do you see them
well if they can go direct to consumer I
think there's a proliferation now of
platforms who are sharing the lion's
share of the revenue directly with the
filmmaker we're 80 20th filmmakers keep
80 we keep 20 and we're not the only one
like that I think it comes from yeah
disintermediated the distribution funds
right so not having quite so many people
in between you and the money that your
audience is spending to see your stuff I
think it comes from working on your
friends projects I think I think it's a
I think it's an amalgam of I work on my
friends movies and everybody gets paid
some piece of it and I make back-end on
those films and I make back-end on my
films because there's back-end to be
made because we're doing this in a more
disintermediated environment I think it
probably comes from brand patronage I
think brands are really waking up to the
fact that it's not about branded content
it is about associating your brand with
the content that audiences are really
excited about this is another
opportunity that's open up totally
opened up to you that you don't have if
you don't have the direct relationship
to your audience you have a direct
relationship with an audience that a
brand is interested in they will pay you
money so that you talk favorably about
that brand to your audience and they're
willing to do it in more and more
creative ways so and we've proven this I
mean Bright Ideas magazine started
because we convinced a brand that we had
access to an audience that they wanted
to associate with really cool content
that they didn't have any say over that
we could associate their name with
brands are really looking for ways to be
prestigious and meaningful this the
other thing is like people think that
brand is a bad word or that brands are
sort of inherently selling out no in
fact there are lots of brands out there
that really want to be a part of this
movement to empower artists to make
really cool important meaningful stuff
you